one of my brothers died when I was five
years old Reed who is the surviving twin
watched David die and he is you know I
don't think ever really recovered for
that I don't know if you can recover
from watching ask what happened is that
yeah he had a cardiac arrest they were
on the rowing machine and he just had a
cardiac arrest a rowing machine was that
was that like an underlying heart
condition like it's just at the gym yep
and the school didn't have
defibrillators they did CPR but could
not revive him it's been 16 years since
David's death now and read spiraled
years after that he left college and
went to India for four years did hard
hard drugs and came back totally
different and then he had a psychotic
break so my brother is now diagnosed
schizophrenic